bonjour dont marty merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors une
trentaine de médecins décédé selon
l'ordre des médecins 16 % des praticiens
de sos médecins infectées par le virus
et chiffres vous paraît style réaliste
bien sûr ils sont réalistes it's ok ils
sont réalistes et ils sont follement
sous-estimé pour la partie contamination
puisque vous savez on n'a toujours pas
les données réelles de des soignants
contaminées en particulier ceux des
villes cela était cachée n'ayons pas
peur des mots et est encore cachées
alors vous avez parlé de colère je crois
que c'est pire que de colère pour au
nectar aimant les dents accusations on
accuse à la fois le ministère et on
accuse le gouvernement d'avoir envoyé au
front des médecins sans nous avoir
protégés ou en les ayant sciemment
protéger avec des matériels qui ne
convenait pas on a donné aux médecins
uniquement des masques chirurgicaux on a
reçu des masques ffp2 ces fameux masque
connard en très très petite quantité en
quantité infinitésimale avec ministre la
santé qui le train smarties et qu'il
avait compris qu'il fallait protéger les
soignants de ville et qu'il allait leur
fournir des masques ffp2 masques ffp2
que nous n'avons quasi jamais reçu
aujourd'hui nous comptons de nos morts
nous pleurons nos morts
et je peux vous dire une chose certaine
c'est qu'on va oublier personne comme à
venir le temps juridique est ce que les
syndicats de médecins ont tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé à cette eau vous
pensez écoutez nous l'a tiré très tôt si
l'on reprend les choses
bon les premières alertes que je lance
sur la nécessité de fournir les
soignants un masque ffp2 quand je dis le
soignant ses hôtes à l'hôpital que la
ville c'est début mars tout début mars
je dis cela et je n'arrêterai pas
d'alerté on écoute la crise dans tous
les bateaux que j'ai pu faire j'ai
alerté là dessus nous avons fait des
communiqués de presse
là dessus nous avons alerté le ministère
nous avons alerté l'état
ceux là n'ont pas compris nous ont fait
perdre énormément de temps parce qu'ils
ont caché les marques de masse qui
avaient ils ont caché la pénurie nous
avons fini par la savoir et être et on a
fini par l'autre dire qu'il n'y avait
pas de masques ffp2 et à ce sens nous
avons lancé l'industrie française
dans la production de ceux ci et nous
avons des entreprises qui nous ont donné
ce que l'état n'était pas capable de
vous donner des collectivités locales
aussi qu'ils ont fait mais on a perdu
trop de temps et puis surtout surtout on
a lié en permanence l'aérosol isation
cette fameuse côte domination qui se
fait appeler des microparticules et qui
fait que les masques ffp2 sur le thème
lisbonne sol quelle action en justice
contre l'état sont aujourd'hui envisagée
par par les médecins pour l'instant il
ya des familles de médecins qui sont
malheureusement décédées qui porte
plainte
romana nouveaux travaux comme défendre
deux voire trois on voit les soutenir
on va aider financièrement cela on voit
la compagnie on se portera partie civile
mais il faut que justice soit faite et
pour que justice soit faite il va
falloir aller effectivement au tribunal
pour que les gens s'explique on a besoin
de savoir pourquoi on a pris avec autant
de légèreté
le traitement de la médecine de ville
vous l'avais dit il ya une différence
très importante entre les drames vécus
par la médecine libérale et les travaux
spitalier qui n'en reste pas moins
important mais on est dans un facteur de
3 à 4 avec trois à quatre fois plus
d'eau de libéro décédé et si ces
libéraux sont décédés c'est précisément
parce que ils ont été mis en face de
patients qui excrété du virus en face de
patients identité en meurthe-et-moselle
en moselle
nos confrères locaux et soeurs voyez 30
40 50 60 cas par jour avec un mauvais
moyen de protection qu'ils inhalent et
de lino qui l'environnent virale de la
particule virale et ils ont développé
des pathologies graves du provident ya
ce manque de matériel et vous parlez de
ces médecins de ville et ce qu'ils
étaient en contact trop proche justement
avec avec les malades
contrairement à aux hôpitaux par exemple
où ils sont pris dans des temps des
unités de soin non mais il était en
contact avec leur passion alors il ya
une constante c'est que on s'aperçoit
que tous les médecins qui saura une
grande partie des médecins qui sont le
décès d un point commun c'était une
grande empathie
c'étaient les métiers très humaine des
médecins très proches de leurs patients
des médecins qui prenait le top
et sans moyens de protection ainsi qu'au
début les quinze premiers jours de la
crise en particulier dans les zones
cluster dans l'est de la france
il aurait dû consulter sans aucun moyen
de protection pour certains et on peut
supposer que le fait cette humanité
cette empathie avec avec les patients a
dû forcément leur leur faire toucher
fait la leur faire et il n'ya de refaire
et gérer ou ou inhalé du virus beaucoup
plus que si l'arrêt était beaucoup plus
éloigné avec avec une sorte de 2,2
comment dire de protection vis-à-vis de
leurs patients mais ce n'était pas le
cas ce qui a manqué c'est les moyens de
protection et encore une fois ils n'ont
pas manqué tout seul c'est moi une
protection ils ont manqué parce qu'on a
pris la décision de ne pas les fournir à
la médecine de ville je vous rappelle la
déclaration des bords philippe premier
ministre qui à l'assemblée nationale
récemment est allez avouez que il avait
fait le choix de donner les moyens de
protection de réserver les moyens de
protection à ses propres mots au
soigneur hospitalier
merci beaucoup jérôme marty d'avoir
réagi sur notre antenne je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin et président du
syndicat union française pour une
médecine libre